you shot a music video and you dressed
up as a guy in the video yes and it was
it's really funny and great and I was
just wondering maybe we'll show a second
of it and then discuss it cuz I thought
you were really good at it let's take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
would you were you channeling who I
think you were channeling for that know
it very much felt like you were doing a
sort of a Justin Bieber and Aleut
there's that some Justin Bieber in there
you have to - the the mustache no no no
but but it was obviously you had a lot
of fun doing that yeah that was a blast
I'm I'm pretty obsessive when it comes
to Jenny Lewis Rilo Kiley's just like my
favorite band of all time so I was
shocked that I was even able to do I
could barely meet her when I met her the
first time and then she's like come be a
total goofball for a day it's just us
girls gonna be so much fun I was like if
I can breathe enough to do that then I
will do and I I did it I'm proud of
myself good you guys
[Applause]
didn't you get really nervous when
because you've done a few movies at
Sundance and you finally got to meet
Robert Redford I've never met Robert
Redford I think he'd be the most amazing
guy to meet you got you got a chance to
meet him and shake his hand and you were
sort of like you melted down momentarily
dude weren't you really nervous when you
Mountain when you met him yeah well we
was we were just about to premier camp
back straight at Sundance and so I was
just nervous about that and anytime I'd
like a little movie it's like you know
you want to champion it and so I was
definitely nervous I think the reason
we're talking about these moments that
I'm nervous because they're so rare
obviously so few and far between might
as well mention them on TV yeah um but
no he was straight-up like hey how you
doing and I was like I had like an idiot
it just went I feel like I'm gonna my
pants
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you